ah the most powerful thing about being a  metal singer is the complete release of  passion I teach people how to scream  effectively without damage but I'm also  a singing teacher  my background is Shakespeare and opera  I got known for being a scream teacher  because I figured this out and I'm glad  I did because everyone was trashing  themselves instead of going red uh I  want most metal kids before they get  trained they think that the only way  that you can get that sound is to feel  that way and that's dangerous because if  you feel that way when you make that  sound it hurts or die and release  everything I teach them the least amount  of effort to do it and then they don't  trash their vocal cords I want seamless  hey metal is like it has a certain  behavior and it's about loyalty it's  real  you  you